où sont les où sont les filles
il s'appelle Jonathan Jacob majeur il
est musicien il est hollandais il a 41
ans et surtout donc c'est un donneur de
sperme en série on estime qu'il a
engendré 550 enfants rien que ça au
Pays-Bas la loi limite à 25 dons pour
les hommes l'objectif étant d'éviter les
risques sanitaires la consanguinité ou
des problèmes psychologiques chez les
enfants
et les cinq premiers points vous avez
souvent dit que vos albums et vos
chansons étaient de leur reflet de ce
qui se passait dans votre lit
affreux aussi donc en 2017 quand la
justice néerlandaise réalise qu'il a
déjà participé à la naissance de 102
enfants il l'exclut des banques de
données en disant tu arrêtes maintenant
ça suffit tu arrêtes de donner ton
sperme petit merci mais visiblement
l'homme n'est pas prêt d'arrêter avec
son petit péché mignon il a ainsi
commencé à faire des dons dans des
cliniques à l'étranger ce qui nous fait
donc arriver à ce chiffre de 550 enfants
ce qui est beaucoup quand même il faut
bien le reconnaître il paraît qu'un jour
l'un de vos élèves on aime bien les
perles d'élèves il vous a touché le
ventre mais pourquoi un élève vous
touche le ventre déjà et ben je ne sais
pas apparemment cette partie là attiré
donc il est venu poser ses mains et tout
Inno sa main il me dit tu as un bébé
là-dedans et alors et alors je me suis
mise en régime
alors il y a un sujet non sur le
troisième je vois où vous voulez revenir
on dit que c'est en général pas les le
même couple c'est ça oui ou que en tout
cas on est plus le même parent on lâche
un petit peu en ce moment la pression et
donc l'enfant non je crois que vous
parlez d'autres choses il y a des études
qui montrent que le troisième enfant en
général n'est pas l'enfant issu du
couple a priori est prévu je ferai comme
ça que je voulais dire ce que j'ai trois
enfants du coup là aussi c'est pas
systématique selon l'Insee les marches
des industriels s'envolent après s'être
effondrée pendant le covid elles
atteignent désormais
48,1%. une moyenne qui ne reflète pas la
réalité de beaucoup d'entre eux selon le
représentant des industriels on est
aujourd'hui à un niveau de marge pour
l'essentiel des sociétés qui est
largement inférieur à l'an dernier il
peut y avoir un ou deux cas
exceptionnels trois caissières d'un
Intermarché ont été condamnés pour ne
pas avoir scanner tous les articles
quand leurs proches passaient à leur
caisse pendant près d'un an des caddie a
plus de 1000 euros qui était en fait
encaissé à moins de 100 Lucie parce
qu'elle est du service polyjustice à RMC
a assisté au procès c'est caissières ont
expliqué avoir été prise dans un
engrenage en mai les 75 plus gros
industriels s'étaient engagés à
renégocier avec les supermarchés mais
aujourd'hui les échanges sont au point
mort seule une poignée d'entre eux sont
en discussion selon le patron
d'Intermarché
concrètement on envoie des courriers on
fait des demandes de rendez-vous et on a
une fin de nos recevoir alors le retour
est assez compliqué puisque au moment où
je vous parle seuls 6 des 75
multinationales sont revenus à la table
des négociations donc c'est bien la
preuve qu'il y a une réticence
évidemment à retravailler le niveau de
marge du côté des multinationales
surtout
pendant 10 mois le stratagème perdure
mais à la fin il faut payer la facture
et le préjudice est énorme selon
l'avocat d'Intermarché 16000 euros pour
un seul mois d'octobre toutes trois ont
été licenciés la première à écoper de 10
mois de prison avec sursis et deux
autres de 6 et de 10000 euros d'amende
c'est de la fausse info et de la fausse
variété je n'aime pas j'aime pas les
sujets qu'ils mettent en avant j'aime
pas la façon dont ils le traite enfin
franchement c'est très très loin de moi
à mon avis Hanouna je ne correspond pas
du tout non plus
alors je l'aime pas du tout
je suis littéralement au bout de ma vie
qu'est-ce qui exprime la joie est-ce que
c'est youpi le 1 ou beurk le 2 youpi
c'est le 1 Burke c'est le 2 qu'est-ce
qui exprime la joie pour 15000 euros et
faire un bon jusqu'au plafond et je l'ai
rencontré dans un restaurant il y a de
ça j'ai plus un an et vous êtes qui vous
nichons
parce que moi je peux pas vous blairer
non plus et donc elle est partie du
resto moi je dis toujours la vérité
quand je croise les dents donc je lui ai
dit que je pouvais pas Laber donc je
pense elle savait que je lui avaient dit
ça donc je pense qu'elle savait que je
l'aimais pas il y a deux miss ok celle-
elle se tiennent les mains celle qui est
à gauche de l'écran va être sacrée Miss
game Mato Grosso elle est donc la
gagnante celle de droite et donc
première dauphine elle a quand même bon
elle a perdu en bas on va pas se mentir
la suite la voici restez bien à droite
de l'écran
[Applaudissements]
et j'ai participé à un concours de
crochet de bigorneaux
alors ça c'est magnifique avec la
coquille avec vous avez craché le
bigorneaux à combien de mètres 5 mètres
ans
la cheminée de la centrale thermique
d'Aramon inactif depuis 2016 a été
dynamitée ce matin du moins en partie
l'explosion pour faire tomber ce symbole
de 40 années d'industrie électrique ne
sait pas tout à fait passer comme prévu
seul la partie haute de la tour est
tombée alors qu'elle aurait dû basculer
en entier 110 mètres de cheminée trône
encore un coup du destin c'est comme tu
veux
[Applaudissements]
c'est gagné